I would say you know as part of making
the pitch video you have to understand
what are you pitching you know what's
your goal you know you what are you
trying to have them by are you trying to
have them donate to finishing fonts or
you have them to try to buy the movie or
you having them try to whatever it is so
you need to have a goal in mind with a
sales tape because that's what a pitch
video is it's a sales tape so what is
the call to action at the end of the
video and then where do you send them
for that call to action you know is it
go to this website is it call this
number is it you know post us on
Facebook is it you know tweet this well
I mean I don't know what you're called
action is but what's the point of the
pitch video just to make a pitch video
you know okay it's a fun exercise and if
you have the time go for it but it's
like you know a good pitch video is a
sales video so what are you selling what
do you want them to do at the end of it
yeah are all of our diet when we were
doing Kickstarter we had a very crystal
clear call to action after we set up the
whole world and explain the journey
explain what we were trying to do the
call to action was please donate
whatever you can right now it doesn't
get much more clear than that you know I
mean in every single thing pointed
people to the donate button that's what
it was that's where we're at well guess
what the site as we move into a point
where you know we're going to be you
know the DVD is actually being
distributed the film is being
distributed the call to action on the
site is going to have to change the call
to action and everything leading to that
call to action all channels and pathways
will have to change too here's how you
get your copy of the movie you know and
whether that's go watch it right now on
netflix or buy the DVD here whatever
that call to action is it needs to be
crystal clear again you may be trying to
get people to the theater or you may be
trying to get people to donate by the
DVD tell their friends about it you may
have videos with different calls to
action I mean it would make a whole lot
of sense if you wanted to have a Twitter
campaign to have a video that you only
really pushed really hard on Twitter and
you were just trying to get people to
tweet that video over and over again
with a different one for facebook and a
different one you know all pushing them
towards your main site where of course
your call to action is going to be by
the movie or help us finish the movie
that's
thing and it's also something that the
studios are doing I mean Paramount
Pictures at that with paranormal
activity you know where they said they
release it in a couple of little
theaters and then their call to action
was bring the bring the movie to your
town and so it's like sign up here set
up here if we get X amount of people
signing up in your town will bring will
bring the movie you know so it's one of
those things for you know again it's
just very like what's your goal what are
you trying to do with this video I do
think a lot of people never decide what
their goal is and you will see a lot of
pointless videos on Kickstarter I mean
we spent a lot of time as you guys know
studying what worked and also studying
what didn't and invariably I think the
videos I saw where I was like okay well
not going to support that film are the
ones where they they either just threw
up a trailer or they didn't really tell
you then ask you to do anything other
than like hey we're making a movie great
you and 10 million other people you know
but I do think that if you're you know
if you're able to explain the people
what you want them to do you're already
so much more likely to get them to do
that so just know what you're asking for
in your pitch video and sales 101 is you
have to ask with a sale right and so
that's the most uncomfortable part but
that's the point you know so if you
don't ask for the sale you can't be mad
that they don't buy yeah and a lot of
artists will feel like oh but I don't
want to ask for the sale that feels so
business E but how else are people
supposed to see your movie you know
don't think of it as asking for the sale
you're asking them to watch a movie
you're asking them this year you're
asking to take the time to see what you
made and you know you need to be
compensated for that even if it's just
the the the cost of you know what it
takes to get it to them but you know
that's that's that's part of being an
artist that wants to survive right but
if you're an artist so you don't want to
ask for sale don't make a pitch video
yeah dipen just put your work out there
and hopefully people will fight it you
know hopefully is there a way to finesse
the asking without
will you turn people off yes that's
where the passion comes yeah yeah you
know it's sharing that passion is that
you know I think I think you know when
someone's banking and you know it
doesn't come from a real place oh
they're just being very you know over
and over and over about it works like I
get it already leave me alone you know
you have to allow people to opt out of
certain things you know what i mean so
even if they've bought in the sale and
now they're constantly getting reminders
every day you know that's no good either
because they're just like enough i
already bought and leave me alone so you
have to be careful with how you manage
your contact list and how you you know
you know follow-up is important and if
they haven't you know but go through
your list and filter out the people
who've already donated you don't of me
or we've already bought so that you know
those people don't keep getting hit and
hitting hand get us out yeah it is hard
with Kickstarter because if you're a
backer you tend to get the updates
unless you uncheck it most people a
little uncheck so they'll still keep
getting updates you have to watch your
updates but you said the most important
thing which is the way to not come
across like you're begging is to be
coming across with something that's an
honest pure and true has you know in our
case Dinah do Letterman it was we had
finished the film and we needed to go to
doc you weeks and we really couldn't
afford it dr. weeks was really expensive
you know and we were able to say this is
why we're raising the money you know and
this is why it's important to us and I
think people saw that we were serious
because one we'd spend our life saving
is making the movie you know to it was
done you know three we were supporting
you know our best friend and his dream
all that stuff was working together and
we just weren't afraid to share that
with people like we felt like we have to
tell him it's the truth I think that if
I had tried to use the exact same
campaign to do you know a romantic
comedy starring me and joke you know and
it's like you know you want to see this
give us money give us money i mean i
don't think anybody would pay to see
that number one but number two it's it's
a completely different ask and you
wouldn't become at it from her from a
different angle so again being honest
from the beginning and be true to
yourself like I we've seen a lot of
young filmmakers who are like he
out they get access to kind of a you
know the lot or something you know and
then they shoot their entire pitch video
like look at me i'm walking on paramount
studios and i want to make a movie a
bubble blonde you're like dude you know
i'm not buying it you know what I mean
like if that's the case and what you
call me for you know it's like if you're
sitting in your apartment you're like
people this is all I got but I really
want to make a movie and I want to get
to Paramount Studios you know I think
yeah I think if you act too cool for
school from the beginning and a lot of
people makers do i'm not sure why why I
know why it's because a lot of people
get into filmmaking for odd reasons and
they want to look cool their friends and
I know you're thinking of one particular
video I'm not gonna say who was but you
know it's just like shot like in the
hallways of like this really expensive
studio and you know this directors
eating a piece of pizza and talking
about how cool it's gonna be if you just
help me get us feel done so what's my
Ward's we badass you know it's just like
and I think he raised $22 ovens 50,000
yeah i mean if you go out the whole
thing like you should donate so you can
jump on my bandwagon yeah you've lost
them I'm not gonna support those kind of
thing and that's also why we're not we
didn't roll right into another
Kickstarter campaign when we finished
the first one you know I mean and I
don't know when we're gonna do another
one but if we do another Kickstarter
campaign is gonna be for something that
were as passionate about because it is
hard to ask people it is hard to ask
people for support it is hard to ask
people for money and you have to ask
everybody you know but I think what
we've learned I mean I was much more
apprehensive on it than you were but I
think we learn more than anything is
that if you're being true to yourself
you have nothing to lose and people feel
it and they got so involved I mean we
still get emails every day like what's
going on you know we want to follow the
journey you know so i think that you
know it's not begging if you're just
stating your case and saying here's who
i am this is why i'm passionate about
this this would go a long way help if
you can
you